je désirais à tout prix échapper aux
chemins de vie balisé qui m'attendait un
travail mariage des enfants
je voulais différents faire des
expériences extraordinaires
c'est pour ça que je me suis retrouvé au
coeur même de la jungle la plus profonde
je te présente un bon pote lieux ciblés
j'ai dit à mes parents que je partirai
pendant un an mais je crois que je ne
rentrerais jamais chez moi
rien n'est plus extraordinaire que la
jungle à nu les insectes les oiseaux
tu as l'impression qu'il te tous dessus
et la sounna il n'y a plus que toi est
ce que tu es venu chercher au milieu de
la table
quoi tu veux comme tous les autres
touristes tout le monde peut aller au
machu picchu mais aller dans la jungle
car il peut nous y emmener
qu'est ce qui te fait dire que karl est
quelqu'un de sérieux c'est pour ça que
tu es là la tribu cacher un équilibre
parfait
le problème c'est l'eau en l'état cancer
car qu'est-ce que tu fous
karl est le seul à savoir où on est et
comment le sortir d'ici et il vient
juste de s'en aller car cette pagaille
et logistique de la rivière vieux sigles
rochelle qu'es tu as une carte et des
gens vont venir à ton sang
tout ce qu'il faut faire
cotis encore encore encore et encore
encore encore encore encore et encore
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
ouais